قد اعترف الجيش الاوكراني بعجزه عن اعتراض
صواريخ اونيكس الروسيه مؤكدا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لا تملك الوسائل اللازمه حاليا
لاسقاطها وقال المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان هناك حاجه لتعزيز الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه عن المدن الساحليه
باستخدام منظومات مضاده للصواريخ
الباليستيه صواريخ اونيكس الروسيه انتجت
في الحقبه السوفياتيه خلال سبعينات القرن
الماضي تبلغ سرعتها 3000 كيلومتر في
الساعه بينما يصل مداها الى 800 كم
من عمان معنى الوقفه الدويري الخبر
العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده اللواء فلنبدا
من هذه النقطه نقطه صواريخ اونيكس وكانت
قد انشات او صنعت بدايه في الحقبه
السوفيتيه لماذا الدعم الغربي لم يمكن
الاوكرانيين من القدره على التعامل معها
الدعم الغربي هو جاء بناء على معطيات
ميدانيه هذه الصواريخ تستخدم للمره الاولى
ولا تعتبر من صواريخ مجازا الجيل الخامس
او الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه وبالتالي كافه
وسائل الدعم سواء الباتريوت وغيرها هناك
تقريبا 15 نظام دفاع جوي قدم الى اوكرانيا
بناء على معطيات انيه ما هي التحديات كانت
صواريخ كاليبر صواريخ كنجال وغيرها من
الصواريخ صواريخ كروز فتمت تقديم الدعم
الان تم استخدام سلاح جديد على هذا السلاح
لا يمكن ان يكون خارج اطار المظلومات التي
قدمت
المنظومات التي قدمت على سبيل المثال
باتريوت ناس سامز وغيرها التي كما قيل
اسقطت صواريخ كالنجر الاح والاكثر تطورا
والقدره على المناوره تستطيع ان تتعامل مع
ما هو دون ذلك لكن السؤال اين توضيع هذه
هذه المنظومات الجويه وما هي الادوار
المنوطه بها وبالتالي الان ظهرت معطيات
جديده لابد ان يتم اعاده ترتيب الاوراق
لمنظومه الدفاع الجوي لتحديد الثغرات لكن
دائما اوكرانيا ما تطلب المزيد وتستغل اي
حدث جديد بان هناك ثغره في الدفاع الجوي
لابد للحلفاء ان يغطوا هذه الثغره دخول
هذه المعطيات الجديده او لواء فايز
الدويري هل هو مرتبط تحديدا برد موسكو على
استهداف جسر القرم وما تلاه من تهديدات
يبدو انها او موسكو بدات في تنفيذها بخصوص
استهداف هذه المخازن للحبوب الاوكرانيه
والتهديد ايضا باستهداف اي سفن
تتجه الى الموانئ الاوكرانيه باعتبارها
حربيه
يعني دعينا نجزا السؤال السؤال تقريبا
اتعامل مع ثلاثه معطيات
المعطى الاول
الان استخدام هذه الصواريخ هل هو اضافه
نوعيه لروسيا ام هو كشف نقاط ضعف في
مخزونات القدرات الصاروخيه المتطوره انا
عملي للجانب الاخر عندما يتم استخدام
صواريخ اس 3 وصواريخ صوفياتيه في دور
الصواريخ ارض ارض ولديها صواريخ كنجال
ولديها كاليبر
صواريخ اسكندر اذا انا اذهب باتجاه ان
المخزونات للصواريخ الحديثه بدات يتم
الضغط عليها الكبير وبالتالي لابد من
استخدام البدائل الاقل دقه الامر الاخر
عمليه
مضيق كرش او مضيق القرم تحدثنا وتحدث معظم
المحللين ان الرد سيكون على استهداف
البناء التحتيه وكنا نتوقع ان يغطي
الاوكرانيه لكنه غطى ثلاثه مدن اوديسيا
مايكولايف
وتم التركيز على اوديسا لماذا لان الهجوم
على كرش تزامنه مع انتهاء وقت اتفاقيه
الحبوب فهنا تم توظيف كلا الامرين في
اتجاه واحد ناتي الان الى المحور الثالث
وهو عمليه التهديدات المتبادله على اعتبار
كافه السفن سفن حربيه انا اعتبره تهديد
اكثر من توظيف حقيقي لانه من الصعوبه ان
اتصور مهاجمه سفن شحن مصممه لنقل الحبوب
بالدعاء انها سفن حربيه او تحمل اسلحه
اكبر اجراء قد يكون كما تعمل ايران يتم
احتجازه قياده الى الموانع على شبه جزيره
القرم او بحر ازوف يتم التفتيش عليها
والتحفظ عليها اما ان يتم مهاجمتها اعت قد
ان ذلك سيفتح قوه جديده في في دائره
الصراع لاوكرانيا بحاجتها ولا روسيا ولا
الغرب سواء فايزه دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من عمان شكرا جزيلا لك